[Music]
and together we'll rule the world from
edge to edge Thank You Kyrie I'll be in
touch
what's he doing here oh he was just
asking questions what are you doing here
but it was quite generous we let you
hang around for six battles now you're
just being greedy with my time
clearly my defense has yet to earn your
respect I respect your effort and I
heard you said nice things about me
after the battle you're worthy opponent
if you like me as your opponents you'd
love me as your teammate free agent talk
we'll wait until after the tournament oh
come on have a little fun gods no you're
not having any air if you want some
scrub go to an eliminated house if you
want to King earn him pure gold it's
funny I thought your throne be made of
salt you're insolent I've dropped 40 on
men for less
they were lesser men oh please didn't I
just dropped fifty on you we are done
here well then I guess good luck in New
York who says I'm going to New York Oh
everybody the garden is the biggest
stage in the realm I would be the goat
if I turn that house around and if you
fail on this biggest stage in the realm
listen to your burner you can't win with
those cats what you need is a dog a
hungry lawyer hound you're proud to be a
dog that's a new one men love dogs
what they loathe are snakes you're
trying to lure me to house Clippers
you're doing an awful job you know now
that I think about it house Clippers
would be a terrible fit I mean we all
know you only take the hardest Road and
house Clippers would be smooth sailing
really got Lord West builder of empires
two Mac slots the best Lord Commander in
the realm and a bunch of hungry loyal
dogs just looking further alpha it's
almost too easy
and besides you came to Los Angeles it
would be so unfair to King James
upstaged night after night in his own
city by the man who was always second
best no for free agents you're very
loyal to House Clippers loyalty is what
dogs do best oh yeah
Kady my turn to sit on the throne I
should be going
you've been very generous with your time
we should talk
maybe if you didn't miss all those who
could have expected then we gather today
to celebrate for if the whispers are
true sir Yanis will be anointed the most
valuable night thank you but how can I
be deemed the most valuable when I
couldn't even get us to their finals
King James used to crush house Raptors
without bringing a sweat they were a
different house then they didn't have
that monster we should be proud we want
60 battles this year yes but it is all
for nothing our tournament is over the
offseason has come and if the maesters
are right Taranto be heading east which
means it's going to be hard for us to
even make Conference Finals again which
is right on we should test the market
maybe sign with house pelicans again or
house pools
I hear house Lakers needs Talent as a
former Knight of house Suns
I know misery and this is not it sure
we're defeated but we are not without
hope for we have the honor of fighting
alongside true greatness not just of
skill but of character the king of the
north may rule the East for now but I
recognize only one true king and his
name is long and full of letters yarnís
a Telugu bow is my king from this day
until his last day do you know what I do
want to be here
last year I fought side-by-side with
King James I didn't think we'd find
another goat in the East not in my
career - I was wrong Yanis is not only
the most valuable knight in the realm
he is the king in East I remember the
days when Brandon Knight was our best
Knight
or maybe it was Ramon Sessions as
giannis has grown so as the dignity and
respect of this house we have not known
hope like this since the days Sorel
cinder and the Big O and it's all thanks
to Yanis the king of the years
[Music]
[Music]
oh how quickly they forget
nine years I released from 3-1 down I
slayed the Warriors from the brink of
baldness I have restored my hairline and
from the ashes of a lost season
I will return rested reborn regrind to
reclaim my throne as the true king
[Music]
all right cut cut
JaVale you jumped on the wrong basket
Melo what are you doing in front of me
why aren't you the banana cuter because
I'm a star LeBron and star Shmi in
leading rope all right well pullin mat
particles stop strangling Derrick with
the physical wire
oh it says here in the script that I
swam 95 miles to kick his ass so I
figured out someone get those guys out
of here
also where did magic go it was supposed
to be here um excuse me can I take Kevin
of Durant in the Mast office no Brandon
just your dope in the wave what's up
endings is me your favorite game of
zones character the Joker you may know
me from such episodes as oh that's right
there are new episodes about house
nuggets so why would you want to
subscribe don't subscribe this show is
done